what is a hypothesis how our hypotheses
formulated and what types of hypotheses
are there that's what we will discuss in
this video let's start with the first
question what is the hypothesis a
hypothesis is an assumption or
conjuncture about a relationship for
example your hypothesis might be man
earn more than women in Germany
our goal now is to test this hypothesis
so we want to know whether to reject or
retain the hypothesis but how do we do
that first of all we need data
data collection we did a survey of 1 000
employed people in Germany the collected
data we can then analyze with the help
of a hypothesis test data analysis for
example we would use a t-test for
independent samples
but can we just test every statement No
hypotheses are not simple statements
hypotheses are formulated in such a way
that in the further research process
they can be tested with collected data
what does that mean in order to test a
hypothesis it is necessary to Define
exactly which variables are involved and
how the variables are related
hypotheses are therefore assumptions
about the relationships between
variables but what is a variable a
variable is a property of an object or
event that can take on different values
for example eye color is a variable it
is the property of the object I and can
take different values for example blue
brown and so on and so forth if you're
doing research in the social sciences
your variables may be gender income or
attitude towards Environmental
Protection
if you're doing research in the medical
field your variables may be body weight
smoke status heart rate
so one hypothesis could be gender has an
impact on salary or there is a
correlation between body weight and
heart rate
but what is it about null and
alternative hypotheses
two hypotheses are always formulated
that assert the opposite these are
called the null and alternative
hypotheses the null hypothesis assumes
that there is no difference between two
or more groups
an example the salary of women and men
does not differ in Germany
in contrast the alternative hypothesis
assumes that there is a difference
example the salary of men and women does
differ in Germany it is important to
note that it is always the null
hypothesis that is tested with a
hypothesis test
thus the null hypothesis is always
either rejected or not rejected learn
more in our hypothesis testing video
in the next step it is now important to
distinguish the different types of
hypotheses
hypotheses are distinguished Between
Difference hypotheses and Association
hypotheses as well as directed and
undirected hypotheses let's start with
difference and Association hypotheses
different hypotheses test whether there
is a difference between groups example
the group of men earns more than the
group of women or smokers have a higher
risk of heart attack than non-smokers
thus in the case of different hypotheses
there is one categorical variable and
one ordinal or metric variable
the categorical variable is for example
gender with male and female or smoking
status with smoker and non-smoker the
ordinal metric variables for example
salary or risk of heart attack what does
this look like for Association
hypotheses Association hypotheses test
relationships or correlations between
two variables an example
the bigger a person is the heavier he or
she is or the more horsepower a car has
the higher the consumption
therefore with Association hypotheses we
have two ordinal or metric variables and
we test for example whether a high value
of one variable is associated with a
high value of the other variable
this now brings us to the directed and
undirected hypotheses
in the case of undirected hypotheses the
question is whether there is a
difference or correlation regardless of
the direction of the correlation or
difference two examples there is a
difference between the salary of men and
women however it does not matter whether
women or men have a higher salary we
just want to test if there is a
difference we don't care about the
direction of the difference second
example there is a correlation between
hate and weight but it does not matter
if the correlation is positive or
negative we just want to test if there
is a correlation
direct hypothesis on the other hand
additionally indicate the direction of
the relationship or difference men earn
more than women the more horsepower a
car has the higher the consumption
so now we know what hypotheses are and
the next video continues with hypothesis
testing we want to find out what our
hypothesis tests and why do we need them
how do we interpret the results of a
hypothesis test and most importantly how
do we find the appropriate hypothesis
test thanks for watching and I look
forward to seeing you right back